los negociadores por un nuevo pacto
nuclear se reunieron en el Palacio Cobos
de Viana el mismo lugar donde se alcanzó
el histórico acuerdo de 2015 al final de
esta primera tarde de negociaciones el
representante de la Unión Europea mostró
optimismo mientras explicó que cada
delegación debe adaptarse a las
exigencias de la nueva administración y
Dani el pasado mes de junio el
ultraconservador Ibrahim Rice y fue
elegido presidente del país
incluidas las que no están relacionadas
con el programa nuclear el principal
negociador de Irán espera garantías
reales
Joseba tirar evaluar y decidir
EEUU sigue presente en la negociación
pero de forma indirecta el enviado
especial de Estados Unidos mail acuse y
dan de paralizar las conversaciones para
avanzar en su programa nuclear una
posición compartida por el primer
ministro israelí Naftali Bennett las
sanciones impuestas a Irán llevan varios
años ahogando la economía del país en
las calles de Teherán estas nuevas
conversaciones suscitan pocas esperanzas
en la población
la gente y afecta a todo
espero que se levante en los próximos
días de trabajo y
el miércoles a la cuestión de la vuelta
de Irán
sobre su programa nuclear en caso de
fracaso se especula con la firma de un
acuerdo temporal en otras palabras la
congelación de las actividades nucleares
más sensibles de Irán cambio de un
levantamiento limitado de las sanciones